someone very smart and very dangerous is
coming after you now why in the name of
God would anybody that doesn't have to
make because your powers
I cannot believe everybody say this but
I think he just made me like country
music okay Barry
yeah it's DeVoe Aaron we're gonna stop
him I know we were know that he there
was nothing keeping him from going
inside the metal wing and absorbing the
powers of every meta and iron Heights a
peekaboo top weather wizard I mean he
could have stolen their powers and more
but he did he only wants to bust meadows
and once their powers for something all
of them hey everybody today is like
trailer day if you guys couldn't tell
they're actually doing the Fiddler
villain from the comics although it's a
country music star this time but it's
the same basic character and it's a
super deep cut from a thinker arc way
back during the Silver Age there was a
fiddler team-up with the shade in the
thinker an older version of the thinker
remember there's been at least three
different versions of the thinker the
version that the TV show has been doing
thus far has been mostly geoff johns era
thinker which is more of a matrix story
but you can kind of see now how the
thinker is collecting other people's
powers and how those powers will stack
on each other like jinxes ability to
alter probability and it just grows like
this probability field that can cover
the entire city you have Kilgore that
can control technology you have black
bison that can animate effigies like
things that are made to look like people
are animals so imagine the think are
stacking all of these abilities together
and what that would enable him to do
just set off whatever enlightenment bomb
that he wants to set off and upgrade the
human race I don't understand as lustily
says Rebecca is she may be the most
formidable of them all field is getting
higher more good luck she experiences
the more bad luck she spreads she must
be experiencing an extreme level of good
luck for a quantum field to be expanding
like this where is she now she went back
to work
guys if Becky keeps winning then bad
luck will keep spreading this could
destroy the whole city okay Keep Calm
all right nothing's going wrong here
guys the particle accelerator turned
back on it's gonna explode he can
hypnotize people one at a time by
roofing their drinks the way he did his
wife at the end of last week's episode
that was the love drug that was excreted
from the tears of that meta from a
couple episodes ago
[Music]
Oh into a lot of trouble creating you
have you running away
not until you've completed the task for
which you up it's basically like
low-grade hypnosis so imagine him being
able to scale that power to everybody
simultaneously but remember we've only
got four of the 12 metas this is subject
number nine it's the ninth meta I know
there's a lot of questions about the
body jumping especially given that Ralph
is part of team flesh there's a new
theory now that he might wind up being
the thinker briefly but there's a big
question about what happens to people
when you jump into their body does the
thinker destroy their mind when he
enters it is he gonna stay in Becky's
body for a longer period of time and
will he jump into a Ralph's body because
that would be a really big twist him
jumping into a character that you really
like that's why they made you like Becky
during that episode oh she's not so bad
she even tried to help the flash out for
a little bit before the thinker took
over her mind so biggest final boss form
Theory he takes Ralph's powers then uses
that to shape-shift into his old body so
it looks like the original version of
the thinker even though technically it's
the thinker's mind in Ralph's body using
his abilities to just make himself look
like he used to look so that would be a
way to get back to the original version
of the thinker and have him be the big
boss while at the same time making one
of our friends the big villain and
making it really heartbreaking but
bringing it back around to the Fiddler's
the Fiddler's ability was mostly based
on hypnosis like you see stuff exploding
here but I don't know how they're gonna
change that for the TV show so it might
be some twists where her music seemingly
hypnotizes her fans like they become
super fans but that feels a lot like the
love drugs so we'll see how they change
it but when the flash fought the
Fiddler's teaming up with the thinker
way back during the Silver Age that was
actually a Jay Garrick storyline too so
hopefully Jay Garrick comes back
relatively quickly but I believe he's
supposed to be around by at least
episode 15 or 16 and I know there's
still a lot of theories about the new
version of the reverse-flash wearing a
different face showing up during episode
15 I haven't seen any confirmation of
that so it's still at the rumor stage
but as you can tell they're pushing more
heavy mythology in the back half of the
season like now that they're doubling
down on their thinker are things are
really getting crazy the other big
question now is is how they going to use
Cecile's powers to help defeat the
thinker because now that she could read
minds the way that the think
can't maybe they can help rescue the
thinker's wife and she'll turn on him
eventually but it just feels too early
for something like that usually that's
what happens around like episode 19 20
21 so in the way the last season you
have Caitlyn switching sides at the last
minute to help out team flash against
saboteur something similar will happen
even though the circumstances will be a
little bit different but just remember
the Geoff Johns thing car run how he
basically covered the entire city in the
effect that he was using to take over
people's consciousness he was basically
trying to become everyone just use
everyone's minds to expand the
processing power of his own mind so in
last week's episode it was kind of the
reverse of that it was sort of like him
sucking up the powers of everyone and
then putting himself in a single body we
might see him try to expand himself by
pushing out into multiple people at the
same time but I think the bigger
question is is what is he gonna do to
the other members of team flash because
there's this iconic panel of Barry
giving himself over to the thinker like
what do you want I want the powers of
the flash the fastest mind alive because
of the Speed Force Barry's brain is
literally the fastest supercomputer on
the planet so while the thinker is
taking over the minds of all the regular
people in Keystone City he's salivating
at the thought of taking over Barry's
super brain but the way the TV show has
done it is with these tentacle things
here just don't be surprised if at some
point this season Barry gets one of
those jacked into the back of his head
but again I think they're gonna push
that off to one of the last couple of
episodes but I'm just expecting a couple
other members of team flash to get
suctioned a little bit like big WTF
twists so I hopefully they'll explain
the mechanics of how that works because
it seems right now once he enters your
mind and takes your powers or either
stays in your body you're effectively
dead so the minute he jumps out into
another body you just collapse into a
lump of flesh on the floor so they're
just a couple of questions that they
have to answer about the mechanics of
how this all works but let me know in
the comments do you think that the
thinker is eventually gonna jump into
Ralph's body and he'll be a villain for
at least a little while if not the final
boss he only wants to bust my toes
he wants their powers for something all
of them we know a bus Mona
hey guys sorry I'm late
just couldn't get this left glute to
shape shift back to its normal perky why
is everyone looking at me like I'm a bit
given the number of times that he's
jumped into different bodies I don't
think that Becky is final boss form so
post all your theories in the comments
below but there is a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and share
the video using those tools on the watch
page there were a whole bunch of
trailers that drop to date so like I
just did that Deadpool video there's
also a venom trailer for that spider-man
venom movie that's coming tomorrow I'll
do a video for that one a post there's a
new Jessica Jones trailer so just click
that bell to turn alerts on so that you
don't miss any of the videos but click
here to watch that Deadpool trailer
again and click here for my episode 13
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight